here we go here we go let's get into
some film let's talk some ball first I
want to say rod Simba every time I
listen to this song it's great let's see
you know it's you read my mind I was
thinking the same thing I was just like
damn this is a good once and there's
something coming for your rod Fendi's
taking care
Oh Johnny Google document talk to him
hello you know we've been DMing
seriously if he's ever up in this area
he needs to let us know or we ever make
it down to the to the Texas again to the
dirty dirt where is he is he in Houston
rod no idea seems like a Houston guy to
me I know he roots for your horn right
your brother to play AFL he is
second-round pick kind of a big deal
like our Twitter blew up yesterday
people be like Matt's in assume yeah
Congrats I was like damn I gotta watch
this league so I had no I was like I was
like I don't want to cover this at all
but he's going to play with that weird
goatee he's got alright he's given doing
this the bit but I call his billy goat
hairs for a while now no one's
apparently told him it's not the best
looking better friends so he got taken
the fifth pic of the second round right
quarterback only giraffe of the a AFL
see they got me talking learning the
letters American alliance of football so
he's going to Atlanta yes don't know
Elena with Brad Childress and Michael
Vick that's why you get drafted
Michael's seen them Michael knows what
he's about yeah some of the quarterbacks
take them in front of them I was like
yeah like Hackenberg went to after him
yeah well so you know those guys are
their names I guess you know so Matt's
gonna play play Matt's gonna play he
does not want to give up the dream okay
which I understand I mean again you and
I we've all talked about this before he
deserves to be in the NFL in some
capacity we know that I do believe so
we'll go down there and crush it
hopefully we'll see where it goes but
I'm a AFL jerseys keep fighting what's
their franchise name the legends land a
legend right all right Atlanta legends
we're officially on board put this clip
out to him Josh Atlanta legends we want
Matt Sims jerseys we're gonna support
the Atlanta legends I'm not talking
about any other team no except the
Atlanta legend yes I like it yeah Matt
Sims oh he's such a my brother such an
odd do
- he doesn't like really ever tell me
he's gonna do the league then my dad
tells me hey Matt's going down to be
part of the workout for this league okay
and oh the drafts coming my mom calls me
Austin hey you know your brothers at the
draft in Las Vegas for those that know I
didn't know he tweeted that he was going
out there oh great you gotta get on
Twitter having apparently I mean he
can't call his brother I know that or
text me but that yeah I just kept
flipping back to see if I would catch
him and then I I'd literally flip back
and he was no they went up there and
interview and I really don't like he was
like a big deal and everything Thanks
we're gonna get some jerseys I'm gonna
get those shipped up here Matt Sims
double AF legends when does their league
start you just spill all of your selling
yeah you filled it up too high now that
was something I would do J you're like
me over there all right Matt simple we
don't have to care but you have to care
about him yeah that's what I'm saying
Atlanta legend / Matt Simms oh there's
this thing happening online right now
that Josh and I think is hilarious we
tried to explain to you which is Le'Veon
Bell being active in the Instagram
comments so Le'Veon Bell all season long
if there's been any post on the NFL's
Instagram page or anywhere else
that's revolving around the Colts yeah
he comments and any time the Colts post
something he comments yeah and then
there was I guess a post about Andrew
Luck and like they're on a five six game
winning streak right now and he wrote
down underneath can you imagine my first
question is yeah
let's imagine yeah Le'Veon Bell on the
Colts would be amazing I think he'll be
my one endorse you love watching the
Colts as is anyway favorite team to
watch you call them what your NBA League
Pass Knight my NFL reddit stream my
dream team okay but let just talk about
what it would be like to cover those
guys I mean you know we always talk
about great offenses and how they make
you defend the whole field
you know the Colts are kind of like that
already they can do that they just lack
some of the superstar players maybe you
need to take advantage of some of those
situations right so Le'Veon Bell the
gifted runner that he is he certainly
could fit in that scheme like LeSean
McCoy could with Andy Reid and doing
that stuff the
cutbacks Oh double pulling guards great
I'll weave my way through there but then
when he does in the past game I mean it
would be amazing it really what I love
Le'Veon Bell not only as a person as the
player - I really like the person yeah
and so it's I feel the same way about
Andrew Luck I feel the same way about
Frank Reich I feel the same way about
Chris Balor yes they're like a team I
kind of want to jump on the bandwagon
with so much Alison Josh and I are today
what you do would you stay up all day I
had a big breakfast this morning
did you yeah I had egg whites and I was
just with some people that's why it was
big okay you know big money guys in the
big time your DirecTV pay-per-view now
they're looking for some serious stuff
you have a tiger in Phil you guys have a
three-way date El Tigre says huh and I
call I call a golf game calm cat call
Cassie pussycat um so ventric and I
looked up Chris Ballard's history with
running backs Edwin his time in Kansas
City before he was officially named GM
and then what he's done in Indianapolis
and the four names that came up that
were acquisitions were Spencer where was
gained on a futures contract originally
drafted by Seattle and future contracts
are like little-known guys that other
franchises have been keeping in there I
on shark and request Kansas City signed
him as an undrafted free agent and then
this year they took my he mimes in the
fourth yeah and Jordan Wilkins in the
fifth right and what that made me
realize was Chris Ballard really has an
eye for running backs because I'd say
that where West Heinz and Wilkins all
have talents right now be right for that
and none of them were better than a
fourth round pick right and I look at
Heinz and Wilkins and I go Wilkins has a
great body
yeah great first step right always makes
moves has a fumbling problem right
that's this issue you said that the big
time funk right right now him Heinz for
three speed right great out of the
backfield if he adds 10 to 15 and learns
how to play in the NFL he's gonna be
good still drops passes has some
penalties but I look at Heinz and
Wilkins and if Marlin Mack can stop
getting concussed and go I don't know if
they need to spend that money I agree
but at the same point they have a
hundred and twenty three million dollars
in cat next year most in the NFL
vendrick and I also looked at the wide
receivers and unless you want to drop a
boatload of money
Larry Fitzgerald or Randall Cobb there's
no big free agents available wide
receivers and I'd argue that you could
take some of the wide receiver money
because there's no wide receivers on
this Colts team other than T Y Hilton
that scares you right and give that to
levy on 90 catches last year it's a
multiple often right so I don't even
know if you need levy on as your main
running back because the wide receiver
market is so shallow in the free agent
market then it does make sense to sign
Le'Veon Bell because sure you don't need
them for running backs but I'm telling
you dude there's no free agents of
interest and they need a free agent and
so there's nobody I'm you know of course
I haven't got down that Larry Fitzgerald
I know look at the teams you're right I
don't
I look at it god I don't recognize any
receivers in the that is stealing a free
agent after this year I don't think so
no good I think he's signed a deal -
it's just very under market right okay
so I look at and go do they go with a
draft but they got their tight ends
Doyle and Ebron they got all these
running backs but maybe they need levy
on just as a guy that could also slot
out I know it's not just the one thing I
know it's it's what everything that he
brings to the table you're right about
that I don't feel like it's going to
happen as much as I would love to see it
because I well because of all the
reasons you just said I just Chris
Ballard running back is one position
okay that unless you're in the top 10
and there's that superfreak they're like
a Berkeley or a McCaffrey or Fernet or a
somebody that's really out of this world
I think everybody goes we can find value
yeah I was running back position Malorie
has proved that he can do that I think
he's got a pretty good that'll that's
what I'm saying yes stop thinking about
levy on as a running back like he wants
you to right are those what the free
agents wide receivers we got the name
says yeah that's not pretty you're right
Larry Fitzgerald Randall Cobb Donte
Moncrief Tavon Austin Golden Tate Ryan
grant John Brown Jermaine Kearse score
Tyrell Patterson Kevin white Mike
Wallace Chris Hogan I'm gonna keep going
the main game there was John Brown right
Cole Beasley cordarrelle Patterson but
even he's not that kind of guy no no to
me it would have to be so when you have
that money yeah and it's gonna burn a
hole in your pocket
what's incredible about what we saw with
their roster yeah we keep talking about
these teams with rookie quarterbacks
that can pay everything else yeah who
are they paying on that roster I don't
other than Angela no I know their
running backs are on the rookie
contracts all their wide receivers other
than t-y Hilton we're getting nothing
their tight ends are very underpaid yeah
their entire offensive line rookie
contracts no one there d-line linebacker
secondary now that's where I look at it
they're gonna they're gonna have to
spend big money on the corners Corner
pass rusher you know receiver ok so then
they have 65 million yeah they still
should have a ton you're right so why
not do it levy on back oh yeah I mean
listen you can do it you certainly can
they're gonna make it work Frank Reich
can certainly pied them all at the same
time yes I mean it's not crazy Chris
Ballard let's say he's coming around to
write the comments under the IG what
happens with their just a levy on beldo
if he gets there right I didn't mean to
cut you off sorry
it's all right I'm just talking to my
brain just a big interrupter his is the
the if you're gonna pay him seventeen
million dollars and he doesn't get the
touches and everything like that it's
gonna start to snowball well why are we
paying them all this money if we're not
getting in the touches why are we
sharing this many characters people like
us I guess I guess yeah I just I'm
saying we keep setting makes I'm saying
like if levy on Bell gets 15 carries a
game right slots out at wide receiver
for 20 times again yeah but then also
it's like you don't need them to stand
there at wide receiver you build your
offense to where it's just past catch
your share different roles sure and then
you can move them in motion and diagnose
the defense you're definitely right
speed sweeps there's certainly ways they
can use them and frankly Reich is
certainly creative enough to figure
another thing they have a coach that can
do it yes he thinks outside the box
GM's yeah do you think they're sitting
there and seeing this guy commenting on
all the IG posts do you think he likes
it
oh do you do you think like the GM's
like it how do you think they're
reacting to this I think there's
probably an old-school certainly faction
of GM's and front office people who are
just like I don't want to deal with this
whatever well I think would be more of
let's say remember how you said that
levy on bail may have had a back door
yes right yeah I still think like the
Jets or that team you don't think it's
the Colts I don't either if you made me
I would think it's the Jets yes and so
he's doing this to drive up the maybe
some values doing some Kirk Cousins
right like I'm gonna go visit the Jets
even though I have no plan on doing that
Oh the Jets made to offer honey this is
what we wanted now we can get Minnesota
to offer me more mmm I mean that's just
at least where my mind goes with it I I
do feel like there is a team that's
sitting there that's already kind of
told them you got a bull's-eye on you
man we're coming against the Jets I have
you made me bet right I have no inside
info that but just reading the tea
leaves or between the tea leaves read
between the tea leaves for they've been
trying to make a splash they tried to
get Khalil Mack I think at the end of
the year Bowles will be the one that
goes I think I'm a cognate at least gets
another year and I think this will be
the splash he tries to bring the town to
help out his sandy the savior
quarterback at number three and kind of
hey I brought I brought help for Sammy
also to that point yeah we are so funny
when we judge GM's we are very
reactionary even though we should be
looking at it three years down the line
yeah
we're it's if he spends a lot of money
and brings a lot of people we always
celebrate them yeah yeah and then if
they do better in their record which you
will because you're not going to be as
bad as you were this year we go wow
those moves were great and then when
they're in salary cap hell in three
years yes we don't even talk about right
but I have some advice for levy oh
please some may call it left go PR right
levy on let me tell you hi my name is
Adam Lefko and I have a PR system for
you you can talk to some of my former
clients namely Odell Beckham jr. you're
sitting home right now you're commenting
under colts post you're trying to get
attention but there's one thing you can
do the left go PR method that's right
once a week post a video of you working
out that's right get in the gym move
some weights catch some balls take some
handoffs run through dummies all you got
to do it is once a week
pick one night maybe a Tuesday maybe a
Wednesday when NFL news is slow and when
you post your video I can guarantee that
other major media organizations namely
bleacher report ESPN heck even Yahoo may
post it
go levy ons keeping fresh eyeball emoji
or uh-oh watch out for levy on
strong-arm emoji all it takes is once a
week and people will think you're in the
gym 99% of the time it's the left go
method and it's available free levia
enjoy that positive feedback it's a
truth though right if for once a week
Le'Veon had himself in the gym with a
music video underneath with some crazy
edits that was just like Winston's with
a Drake song underneath of it people
will be going uh-oh here comes levy on
oh man so much better than Connor
Steelers are gonna miss out on them it's
just once a week I hear you you steered
Odell in the right direction he like he
was whether he likes to admit it or not
he was listening oh yeah I know it's a
foolproof method it is a foolproof
method I think the other thing we have
to learn should call it the DeAngelo
Hall no no who's the guy that went to
the Nets that was on the Lakers
right right because that was the guy
that made me think about this right
where he posted the one video of him
working out at 3:30 in the morning yeah
and everyone's like wow I'm like one you
have no idea if it's 3:30 in the morning
and - okay what does it matter if he's
working on 3:30 in the morning or 3:30
in the afternoon yeah but you know when
you do like unconventional things it's
crazy yeah what was the one thing we
have to look at I guess if we wanted to
deep dive that conversation further all
right
the thing the next thing I would look at
and maybe this would be the next podcast
though is receivers that are all going
into their last year of their deal right
that would be another next guy level
like where you go because those teams
could be those receivers could be traded
right that could be sellers or they
could go you know what we can get out of
this contract right now no I wouldn't
think so
but you know I don't know why I'm just
gonna say this I don't mean even make a
hot tanker but listen I still don't
think Odell Beckham jr. zout of the
woods in New York
I really don't when you continue to say
things like he did this last week What
did he say that caught your attention
that the game plan should a mature
attack the secondary more and things
like
that with the family that's the Mehra
family and then a guy like Shermer I'm
just I'm just and then Dave gentleman's
the GM I'm just saying that's not gonna
sit well with those people when they're
constantly being second-guessed by the
highest-paid player they're one of the
highest-paid players on their team I
don't know why I'm saying that but that
would be the next level to look at guys
in that situation who are your left
whoever it may be that would be trade
partners with Kristen or Zorich
over a salary cap casualty hit where
this team just goes you know he's a
little up there in years now and we
don't want to pay him 15 million a year
anymore I got the names of the guys that
are gonna be up in 2020 do you so you
want him yeah that's here
AJ Green okay Demaryius Thomas right
DeSean Jackson Emmanuel Sanders I'm just
going to ones that matter
yeah Mari Cooper Wright Edelman Cameron
Meredith Willie Sneed Devante Parker
Nelson Aguilar Michael Thomas so that
whole giraffe crap yeah okay but that's
me Tyree kill right I don't think he's
getting Terry kill so that's those kind
of guys though okay yeah it would be a
maybe Cincinnati rebuilding and we're
gonna trade away AJ Green then leave I
know I'm just saying that's the AJ Green
and T Y Hilton would be amazing right
yes but that was where I was going with
it looking for those type of guys just
for the least of name sake guys Monday
Night Football
Texans Titans and Texans have won eight
in a row yeah I tweeted this out during
the game this that game was the reason I
picked the Texans as a surprise Super
Bowl team again I was going out of the
limb because I wanted to because it's
more fun to but that combination I even
put in that connotation on it why didn't
you just think they were gonna win it
you like to be right you also say that
so don't give me both [ __ ]
Walter because do the reason I do right
the Sikkim yeah the reason that I really
picked him was they had the combination
that it takes to upset the patrons
because when I'm picking my AFC team I'm
either picking the Patriots or a team
that's capable of winning in Foxborough
right other than that I'm not betting on
anything they have a front for that
generates pressure that you could drop
seven and what I saw at a JJ Watt the
other night he's beyond back he that
looked like
a watt three years ago and Covington is
Covington is a little I don't want to
say he's at Sheldon Rankin's level but
it's a bigger guy than that my thing
with Covington is if you if you're gonna
have Jadeveon Clowney and merciless and
what you have to win your one-on-one
yeah and he did it right they have the
playmakers in the back end with Matthew
and Joseph and with who's our Jackson
Kareem Jackson and even that rookie
linebacker really good read I know
really just baller that's Eric Reid's
brother yeah yeah Wow and then you have
the offensive weapons Lamar Miller speed
and a quarterback that can do anything
yeah they are a team that could go to
Foxborough and really make it tough I
agree and that was the reason I picked
them but I still have a lot of serious
doubts especially if they have to play
on the road right but where you see like
they're the doubts I think the other
thing that you and I both doubt with
them is is their offense schematically
diverse enough cuz you saw even in that
game in the big plays it's still
Demaryius Thomas one-on-one with a guy
and DeSean making it great three or
DeSean scrambling and running or
scrambling and then making a great throw
yes so yeah that's the r-1 I guess
question we still need to see from that
I want I want one of those tight ends to
really step forward and yeah a big
viable weapon because when you play the
Patriots they're gonna take away DeAndre
hop yes right and they're gonna go beat
us with Demaryius Thomas yeah and you
need someone else to step on a question
but they're operating I mean that's
eight in a row in a row and I mean again
the o-line what they did again I mean
it's just they're a mauling group up
front no they're not like the greatest
o-line in football but the one thing is
is they're built to run the ball inside
with the kind of bodies of people they
have at garden center and Lamar Miller
as you see he's kind of one of those
guys when he's got a seam he can go zero
to 60 in three steps and outrun just
about anybody that was impressive that
he out round that there was some there's
some fast people in that secondary I
wish it Dorie Jackson I was in the
position that he could have really made
it close the car oh yeah right
because the car almost got in his way
right cuz a Dori was a rocket at the end
then I was
I love watching that you know what they
did they did show a highlight mix during
that of a dory had a little bit of what
you talked about with denzel ward he
stays with the guy but where are the
ball skills to make the play when the
balls in the air definitely in a few of
those the other night he just didn't
look up no didn't look up too many of
these guys play into the receiver and
then playing the ball itself yeah it's
it's actually something I go crazy about
every week I don't get stuff cuz he's
right there I know Mariota does the
Dawson and loses which I can't imagine
again the Dawson is more touchdowns than
incompletion right Eli did it but to get
that loss it should it showed me a few
things one that's the NFL we're in today
yes it is where it's so easy for
completion percentage right but also I
thought Mariota played well and then
they lost by double digits Mariota is
thrown the ball great he really has but
the Texans I think just more than
anything again like the other good teams
in the sport we see right now they put
pressure on you on every play on both
sides of the ball I think that's where
they separate themselves where other
teams you know the Titans are just
trying to hang on or you know let's get
a few first downs here and see if we can
get it a rhythm you know the Texans are
going we're gonna try to get a sack
fumble here or yes we're gonna play some
crazy coverage and try to get a pick six
and they get burned by that sometimes
but their offense is the same way we're
gonna run the ball try to take it to the
house or we're gonna fake that run and
then throw a play-action pass to try to
go to the house with it I just talked
really positive about Jay Jay so I want
to say one thing yeah two things one
most camera aware NFL athlete I've ever
seen he makes a big play he's kneeling
down helmet comes on looking up and I
appreciate that that's a good PR did you
see the one where he tried to sell a
hold early in the game by holding on to
the offensive lineman's arm and then
falling I do remember the arms out I
just can't remember and then he just
walked around the field for like four
minutes with his hands out I just jay-j
cracks me oh he's very aware of where
the camera is pregame every day I don't
think you can reach that level of
awareness until you're that good at
everything else it goes back to like
what we talked about Aaron Rodgers
smiling or Cam Newton talking to
somebody at the line of scrimmage like
yes it's only those kind
guys who can your right be that
self-aware and yet just go uh it doesn't
matter I'm gonna go out here and kick
everybody's ass out here on the field
all right those teams are in the AFC
South so are the Jaguars I would say the
most disappointing team of the NFL
season and Tom Coughlin was on a radio
show and explained why they kept bortles
and he said quote we were all whistle
away from the Superbowl we're a whistle
away we're in the Superbowl and that's
my position okay
so tell me everyone out there what
they're gonna do in that circumstance
about your football team before I keep
going for you to be the GM or have the
30,000 feet view of your team and think
that in the NFL where you've been a part
of for like three four decades it's been
your life that you think that you're
just gonna come back the next year and
run it again
that's insane yeah that's it because I
know they got Norwell and all that stuff
right but to not be able to critic but
for a GM to go we were a whistle away
and to sound like Johnny Jacksonville
fan yeah to not critically evaluate your
quarterback and go look where we got and
did not give all of that credit to your
defense
mind blowing yeah let me finish this and
their run game I mean it's the number
one run game in football last year was
the Jacksonville Jaguars quote are you
going to fill other pieces in and try to
be as good as you can be and we tried
didn't we well the nature of the game
got us so we got to go back to the
drawing boards but I'll put the gloves
on with anybody that wants to talk about
the moves that we made so Tom Coughlin
just said I will fight anybody that
wants to talk about the moves
aka Blake yeah I mean I guess he's also
trying to refer to what like DJ Hayden
Moncrief like you said Norwell so
there's been guys there I get that
no but the the move is one move the move
we're talking about and you know they
got oh gosh we did good we don't know
what we're gonna get from if we sign a
free agent quarterback he played good in
that AFC championship game and that was
it they got fooled by all the same crap
that a lot of the people who
tried to say Christams you're an idiot
for saying Blake bortles is that bad
they got fooled by all that and then
they just didn't want to upset the
chemistry of their football team which
right you know is which I think you kind
of need to there's nothing wrong with
that okay and you know I guess what my
biggest thing with that whole
conversation is you know going back to
what we've said a few times already with
this is you know the formula in which
you played last year did you really
think that was gonna be totally 100%
realistic again team stay healthy like
it did just smash people running the
ball downhill people are gonna watch
that do you really think your defense
can be able to create all those you know
optimal positions for your offense
whether it's pick sixes or you know
strip sack fumble or an interception in
the AFC divisional game that gives you
the ball first and ten at the 18 yard
line to start the game and you get the
ball one play in Leonard fournette runs
for a touchdown historically if you lead
the NFL and takeaways it's not gonna
happen exactly the greatest defense
we've ever talked about right the two
greatest defenses we ever talked about
one went to one Super Bowl never went
back the other has never even went to a
Super Bowl so why would you think that's
going to happen again the Bears went to
one Super Bowl your Philadelphia Eagles
in the ladies and early 90s big Phil
would tell you those defenses were
better than the 85 Bears and they
couldn't even get to the Super Bowl
so what made you think that you were
just gonna be able to win with that same
formula I guess is what I questioned I'm
realizing right now right why is it that
the greatest defenses of all time had
poor quarterback play yeah the Denver
Broncos a few years ago had a 19
interception Peyton Manning the Ravens
had Trent Dilfer Dilfer the Bears had
Jim McMahon very well-loved but never
discussed in terms of great quarterback
play the Jaguars have Blake bortles it's
it's why is that it I don't know you're
right the Seahawks have Russell Wilson
so it's not yeah but it was also a young
Russ it was like your second junior
Russell Wilson Trent Dilfer the Ravens I
mean did a daunting
do it for Dell for no but it isn't that
funny though it's it is funny it's just
proof that your theory can't have it all
no you can't have it all can not have it
all and you know what happened to them
this year is Leonard fournette getting
hurt Andrew Norwell getting hurt you
know who's the big level Linder got hurt
our cam Robbins cam Robinson got hurt so
then all of a sudden now we can't
dominate the line of scrimmage and just
push forward into second and six every
time that's my offensive line theory
yeah remember it's if an offensive line
if all five play every game yeah just
factor in in your predictions that
they're gonna be decimated yeah every
year it happens with the Cowboys this is
a healthy year right next year will be
an unhealthy year yeah that's kind of
how it goes my other question though
with the Tom Coughlin he says I'll put
the gloves on anybody yeah
if Tom Cotter chance oh okay you say
he's fight me there's no chance I wait
I'll say that if Tom Coughlin was
fighting me who would you bet on you got
him man you think I would be really I
mean he's gonna make you nervous and
he's gonna talk some real good old man
crap to you he's gonna come in technical
and wavin it's I always put myself I'm
in the corner you're with me in the
corner right I Spit I put my headgear on
and then I come out and here's this old
wrinkly Coughlin that didn't sit down
because he needs to show me that he'll
always be on his feet and he's sitting
there and right before he put to this
mouthpiece I'll be like I've been in
wars right and I'm like holy crap right
and he has like this fullback tattoo
that I never knew existed and it's just
names crossed out all right so the first
round would go by and you might not do
that great but then I'm in the second
round on the corner I'm gonna tell you
I'm like hey left go work come on yeah
just go effing crazy he can't hurt you
he's got no power he just sees all
technique and moves just take a few
shots on the face you'll be fine you got
all that cushion and your breasts there
to open it up let them hit you there and
wait for your one good one and you'll
put him to sleep I would train so hard
because getting knocked out how old is
it 72 72 you know one round boxing match
two minutes
oh that's scary
he might out technical left cause that's
we're talking about points I was talking
about it with Matt Waxman he's 72 and I
said in a one-round boxing match I would
have a hard time betting against Tom
Coughlin Tom would be all over it okay
I'm gonna win this I feel like time we
were like spider monkey right and I'd be
like no where did this energy come from
speaking of getting punched and getting
hit good transition left go I don't even
know where you're going I was gonna say
nothing is more painful than being hit
by a bus oh and nobody throws people
under a bus more than Big Ben but I
think you agree with him here so he said
about James Washington
if you don't know Denver Pittsburgh game
second half beautiful throw by Big Ben
rookie wide receiver James Washington
wide open he jumps for it seemingly
catches it hits the ground ball pops out
Steelers have to punt right one of the
many mistakes of the Steelers in that
game right Ben said Monday in a radio
appearance that James has to make that
catch I just think he didn't trust his
hands for some reason he jumped over I'm
not really sure what he was doing we
looked at it on film coach got a pretty
coach got on him pretty good yesterday
we took a long hard look then all of
this public outlet outcry Ben's thrown
another guy under the bus all that stuff
he came out there today and said I think
I've earned the right to kind of say
this honesty because I'll be critical of
myself in the media as well I mean we
did applaud Aaron Rodgers in the
preseason say that the young rookie wide
receivers needed to step it up yeah Big
Ben does not hide from criticism himself
he does not he says I play better or
maybe I should retire when a you lot
through the five interceptions
Jacksonville but on your notes on that
play you I looked and you wrote what the
[ __ ] are you doing what the WTF are you
doing would be too devastated
Washington's yes I got the play right
here you know what I've already watched
okay multiple times it makes no sense to
me what he's doing and if you haven't
seen it you can watch it again to read
it was in step it was in step it's
literally like he is the ball is inches
from his hands in step and he decides to
just jump up in the air as he's doing it
and go let me jump
and the worst thing about it is he
caught it I'm not even sure he's gonna
be inbounds he was gonna jump himself
out of balance - I don't understand that
and you know yeah so Burt bet might I
don't look at that as theydon't throwing
him under the bus in this situation guy
that's still earning his stripes in the
NFL he does need to make that play that
was ridiculous in that moment to do that
right there
I wonder why if you don't trust your
hands catching would make you feel more
coming jumping would make you feel more
yeah it people do do that at times I
guess it gives you a little bit of a
softer feeling like I'm in the air and I
can kind of like you know that like egg
drop - yeah oh it falls into my hands
softly there's been guys throughout my
career where you know you they do that
you know you call or I call them spot I
would call them like spot left go
wherever you catch it that's where we
spot the ball cuz you fall down every
time I throw it to you because you know
it's more safe to catch it let me just
follow the spot because that's where you
spot the ball right just spot it like a
dam I threw your slant perfect and you
can ran for a 70 yard touchdown but
instead we're spotting the ball seven
yards exactly where you can tell us who
or is that like Adam oh let's do another
let's see I used to call my tight end a
Texas spot it's Chad Stevens I called
him spot Stevens yeah big big strong guy
every time he caught he just like
engulfed the ball went down well it
definitely is scary when the balls on
target there you go if I drop this it's
all kinda yeah but everyone is is kind
of coming after Ben yeah and I think
it's because he has had a history of
this martavis Bryant Antonio Brown
always a different guy but this time it
sounds like he's actually a right I know
was like that just Ben has just kind of
dug himself into being an [ __ ] he is
there anything he does he's either
faking an injury or he's an [ __ ]
I guess he doesn't need to say this
right unless he feels that truly this
guy needs to hear this publicly to put
the pressure on him and if he has that
feel then go ahead like he said he's the
captain of the team Ben will always be
severely underrated as a player because
I would say 90% of the people that I've
ever met or Nome don't think he's a good
guy or don't like him so it's gonna hurt
his standing among the all-time great
status you know where I think I think
he's like borderline in the top ten of
all time type a quarterback
I mean somewhere in there I mean you
know he can say I give you go anywhere
from 8 to 15 8 to 18 I think he's been
that good but it was crazy by James
Watson and James Washington has to catch
those type of passes because he's gonna
be open that's what he is - he's an
outside guy so he's and he's not a great
guy he has one direction which is
forward it's it's really it they need to
for me just why we're on that game real
quick they one of the problems with
Pittsburgh's offense right now is they
have to put in Tony O'Brien on the slot
more they kind of stop putting them
outside I don't know why they don't I
don't know either and I don't know if
it's they don't trust anybody else to be
that guy because they have Switzer who's
the slot guy so I think that gives them
their best story on the field of times
and Switzer can't play outside so then
they're they have to keep juju and Brown
outside and if Washington was able to
play on the outside right then you could
put a B on there and go okay we can do
this or we can mess with juju na be in
the slot and give some formations that
would make it hard to double a B in
certain situations and things like that
but I they're having a hard time finding
that guy there have been some people
that have hit us up about creating our
own QB metric oh I know since you don't
like QB r and you're not a fan of
quarterback rating yeah
do you like QB are more than quarterback
I do like QB are more than quarterback
rating yeah I do I think there's a
little more value in the you know I
guess what do I want to say the the
moment of the throw and what you're
doing as far as being evaluated Layton
game late in the end of the half more
value about game changing plays instead
of all being about completion percentage
is what the quarterback rating is all
about if we were to kind of enlist some
of our fans to create a metric what
would be the things that you would care
the most in fact during a quarterbacks
yeah rating of course touchdown
interception ratio explosive pass plays
in the air right now that I don't I'm
not getting Europe mate you threw a
screen behind the line of scrimmage he
ran for 20 yards whew that was some play
by you you don't know where the ball
travels right plays longer than 20
you're right in the air right yards
percolation team yards for well I'm just
saying you can find whatever guard line
that is if you want to say 10 yards
whatever it is what 20 yard
for completion is more of a useful stat
to me than yards per attempt okay
that would be another thing I think
those who've seen some of the things I
would look at and then you know man I
don't know what you would say difficulty
of throws that to be the hard part
right you know okay you had to gather
the pocket or this guy's really covered
and you made it great throw like that
that's a hard one to do but I think the
other ones me so maybe that would just
be froze under pressure so throws under
pressure right something like that yeah
yeah don't we how do we quantify mahomes
a--'s arm
changing what the Chiefs are able to do
on offense yeah that's another good like
I know maybe so many things but I do
think there's got to be a better way to
have a formula because it's really
interesting especially the last few
weeks with Mariota and Eli Phillip
Rivers going like 28 of 29 the QB rating
I think there's I don't even know how
many guys are over a hundred I feel like
it's 70 I think it is six or seven I got
it right here if you want it yep it's
let's see the top 13 or at a hundred I
mean that's insane insane I'm just
telling you in 1990 or 89 the number one
rated quarterback in football was Joe
Montana and he had a ninety two point
three quarterback rating and everyone
was like man I remember Jeff your series
like 96 the way this is his story
exactly right I mean Steve Young back in
the day when he was in the 98 or 102 's
that was unheard of
I mean Drew Brees is at 127 right now
that's insane Patrick mahomes 117 last
year there were five quarterbacks that
finished the season over a hundred in
2016 there were five as well in 2015
there was seven there were six yeah so
13 I mean this is like double or triple
Ryan Fitzpatrick so that tells you that
there's a problem not only with the
league but the way the quarterback
rating is done okay I mean damn I mean
the quarterback rating should be
somewhat of a correlation to how good
you are as a player right Ryan
Fitzpatrick is nowhere near the 13th
best quarterback in football I mean I
don't know what it was say it and if
there was a stat out there to quantify
the dumbness of some of
interceptions and things he does those
are the things that we lose in this
quarterback were in this quarterback
rating our or what another thing we lose
Aaron Rodgers thrown a big pass down the
left sideline Davante Adams pass
interference the pressure he puts on the
defense to get that because he's such an
on the money throw I mean there's just
so many factors it's very hard really to
come up with it I don't know if I can
really do that well no I'm not expected
out I do I'm hoping somebody else yeah
right
but yeah it's like we talked about Drew
Brees meanwhile Patrick Holmes is number
two a hundred and seventeen point nine
yes let's just throw that statistic out
there and I don't need to get into a
Patrick mahomes drew Brees thing I could
do it at any time just let us know if
you want us to yeah it's already over -
what do you mean Brees is gonna win the
MVP it's the the masses have won media
will not let it go
we are the media and I will fight back
I'm just saying there's a reason of why
I'm excited for Thursday Night Football
the Cowboys let's see if they can get
there I don't think it's gonna happen
but I'm hoping DeMarcus Lawrence put
some balls in the air
let's call Phil we're a little early
let's see how he handles when were let's
see yeah let's see if he's ready we're
gonna call that a house I got a few
questions what are we gonna talk to him
at you got questions for him well I want
to ask him about apparently he's in How
I Met Your Mother
okay and I have a Saints theory that I'd
like to run by you okay anything else
cuz we haven't talked about this
anything else better when we don't all
right um but yeah if you think of
anything please
plenty ping pong on Thanksgiving no we
were at my house you have a table no
he's not gonna be ready whoa
all right call me back just call me
right back all right all right all right
we called you early don't worry okay so
apparently in How I Met Your Mother
Jim Nantz is in it and he says the line
there are two things you don't do one
you don't email open an email from Phil
Simms in front of your kids and to you
don't jinx a man going for a perfect
week oh I mean I don't even know my dad
knows how to use email it's pretty crazy
it really is we
doesn't understand I use email I'm just
shocked that he does I just you know I
can't really imagine him going through
his emails it does Phil Simms use emojis
no definitely not now he does use
abbreviations like he's the king of lyk
or let you know or T talk let's talk to
you later tty yeah that's what he says
and I'm not good with those and I'm like
what the hell is he doing with this crap
talk to you later
like that that's what he's good at wait
hold on he just texted me
okay he's ready he's ready call him at
home Nikki
ttyl let me see
there's nothing anything else comes to
my mind does it take that long to doubt
you know so you know the numbers we're
gonna come at you're gonna come at us
after you weren't ready geez I'm ready
you called early you know I couldn't
believe it
well if we're it's it's Jacksonville's
tom coughlin time things are
straightening up in the world he gets
time you guys are far from Jacksonville
well maybe not now we were talking just
now tom coughlin says he's willing to
put the gloves on to anyone that
questions what they did and then the
follow ups discussion was if I fought
Tom Coughlin one round two minutes how
would I do well
two minute round one round set yes if we
fought like to need yeah but you know
Adams still not sure he can do it he's a
tiger cat if he would dance around for
the first 30 seconds I'm sure Adam would
run out of air by then so yeah he might
whoop your ass and I'll tell you what he
comes up here in the summer lives what
Christopher 200 yards from me 300
whatever not far as a place and he's I
see him out constantly big hat jogging
walking this that yeah I think I don't
do those things so that's an advantage
jump about every day I mean you know he
would like a little fight yeah that's
what I'm saying I think I'd come in
there and be like portal sucks and he'd
be like come here I'm gonna kill you
No
might say oh you might be right there
but I still don't like you so Phil we
had some people messaging us asking if
you can shine a light on how this
happened in the show How I Met Your
Mother
Jim Nantz says the line there's two
things you don't do one you don't open
an email from Phil Simms in front of
your kids and I was curious are you
known to send scandalous emails that is
absolutely not true what is it well go
Rider who is that Christopher negative
ghostrider
watch movie 50 times felt like you did
as a kid growing up but no I asked you
Adam I asked my son right there have I
ever sent a text to you or anything with
even one curse word in it no you have
not actually just telling them you're
the king of the abbreviations of like
ttyl or you know lyk or l ykl you use
all that stuff I'm always like who the
hell is this guy yeah no I don't curse
on the thing I'm my cursing person every
once in a while not as much as I used to
you know when you grow up in a household
with all my brothers and sisters and my
dad would be laying on the couch you
know we have one couch he'd be taking
you know his nap at night after we had
dinner and all of us are in the TV room
trying to watch TV and my dad would be
snoring on the couch and he would be
later store and he'd be going he'd be
calling out people I'm gonna beat beat
beat your ass beat beat beat you know
we're all just look at each other start
laughing and it's true and it was like
gonna happen every time he would start
even cuss people in his sleepy Boulder
to sleep Dan so that's why we're so
psycho in our family oh yeah well you
could you you can verify this story when
you see you know if you ever go see my
brothers and sister down in Kentucky son
that's another thing but that's a well
let this go but they'll verify do you
know it was really hilarious for him to
be talking to people and using the
language he used you know why he was
sleeping that's also well willing to see
one put it on pay-per-view
I'd probably buy it nice
pay-per-view I usually buy it that makes
sense I have a question that I want you
and Chris to chime in on Sean Payton
Drew Brees Tom Brady Bill Belichick who
has the stronger who has the stronger
connection ooh
the stronger connection in what way what
do you mean is people just personal like
working everything yeah like we think
it's it's Sean Payton Sean Payton sink
yeah he's such a grinder but he does it
with a you know personality too and has
fun doing it I mean he you listen as a
quarterback to really fun right right he
lives through the quarterback - right he
lives it he's living the quarterback
like we've said a thousand times he
thinks he's drew Brees and then drew
Brees is only doing that because he's
coming through my body out there and
that's your experience because I did it
and hey he's Drew Brees is playing
quarterback like Sean Payton thinks he
would have played if he was the
quarterback that's what's so cool about
it and yeah and we all know that and Jon
Gruden the same guy - he wants to do all
those with you Christopher 90,000 checks
getting a perfect play because that's
who I would be I would be the smartest
guy out there right and but Sean Payton
I always tell people and you know our
son you know Matt got to go down there
and spend a couple days with them in a
mini camp two years ago right some of
the year before and I said it'll be the
best days you've ever spent in football
and after the first day he called and
says oh my gosh and I was you know and I
knew I said yep what'd I tell you
just the way they coached who they are
they talk like normal people they you
know they they're emotional they're out
loud you know everything that you kind
of can relate to you know and like as I
think it's a player and I even text
brandon marshall who's down there now
and maybe i didn't quite go into that
but he just he goes man they are all
about ball down here i think was kind of
his quote which was not really cool so
here's what's interesting when I hear
that right
they talk like normal people and they're
all about ball right what are the other
coaches like they're just go ahead no
you know III mean it's hard to say
they're just for lack of better phrases
more of a man's man
there's no political BS if you play like
crap or did crappy and practice you know
hey [ __ ] left go you suck today I mean
you were [ __ ] horrible yeah but make
it like they'd let you know but also not
make you feel like you're like the worst
thing on earth and so what other coaches
to the other coaches Ivy League's are
just a little uptight it's professional
I don't know what it is they're not
willing to take the chances right it's
so many different ways and yeah the ones
hey
it wants you become very honest I think
with athletes it takes a little bit to
get used to but once you get used to it
you like it because you know where you
stand right and it might take a little
bit you might get your little feelings
hurt you know I got mine hurt some too
and even once I learned it just like oh
my god you know let's give me a break
here you know Bill Parcells just was one
day let me just come in and not be under
stress as I sit in the meeting room
going oh my god I hope I have a good
practice I mean I would start sweating
an hour before practice going damn I
hope it goes well and hope it's not too
windy that's that you know my god it was
brutal but butt beat he was always
fruitful I mean really and you know
really blatantly truthful sometimes like
you you don't want to hear it you know
I'm telling you son I mean don't make me
oh hell I'll pull you high yank you
you better sergeant like oh my god yeah
I don't think he ever told me that but I
think he inferred it a little bit as a
threat which I didn't really believe
either but that's the way it goes well
I'm Payton Sean Payton like other than
bill but I I would have I don't know
Sean that well only in passing hello but
the things I've heard like comparing
again Bill Belichick is never gonna get
that close to Tom Brady or give him that
praise or make him feel that way that's
just not his style that's gonna praise
him after his careers over right now
he's still his coach and he's gonna push
his buttons to drive him the right way
we're where we've said like Sean Payton
makes the quarterback feel like men he's
were teamed together out there what
about Sean and Drew versus Josh and Tom
yeah I still think josh is more like a
Belichick than a Sean Payton like this
is where I would further I think Sean
like going to the guys are man's man
talk or whatever
like I think he's the kind of guy that
would tell you like and I had five beers
last night and I did this so now you
can't believe I did this and then I did
that what an idiot I am where you're
never gonna get that talk from Bill
Belichick where I feel like Sean Payton
might give you a little look in his
personal life too like and what does
that mean to you as a court I think it
just lets you know the person a little
bit and you just go okay this guy's on a
robot like he goes home and drinks beer
or whatever else and you know I think
Belichick we're just like he's the
sergeant he's the drill commander
whatever he says we do
he gives us a piece of paper we read it
and say yes coach and it's just a
different way that way yeah it's a
different way and it listen but they
both have one thing in common they hold
you extremely accountable and they are
in control of everything and they coach
everybody and you know that that's what
I always you know I look back I used to
go about coaches like why I always refer
to Bill Parcells because I've spent
eight years with him and we had success
and of course he changed a lot of lives
but he'd be back there you know coaching
the punt returners I'm going what the
hell is he know about returning the punt
but it wasn't about to he hadn't know
anything he just wanted to be on them
and show them that he was with them too
and by god I'm judging you like
everybody else like your star wide
receiver or whatever and get your arms
under do this you know I mean they'd be
right beside him you know and and rule
what he was doing putting them under
pressure in practice situations right to
make sure they didn't drop it during the
game and I just saw Tom going man I know
one of those guys like to catch a punt
and take the ball and just throw it at
him I just thought of a fill I just
thought of a random question yeah when
you were there in the Giants and
Parcells is there in balichek's there
was there ever a day when you looked at
Belichick and thought he's going to be a
better coach than Bill Parcells well no
no I don't know if anybody did I think
the defensive players is I've heard him
talk over the years just used to go wow
you know that that things he would teach
him in the meetings and talk about and
and and designing stuff and all that day
they were just that caught their
attention ago man he's unbelievable but
I don't know if they thought he would
ever become what he is and you know I
don't know I think Christopher we talked
talked about it I think he played cover
to the
we went to our first Super Bowl
basically almost every play of the year
right and he never took a safety we
never had a safety out of the middle we
always had to back her one back but most
the time it was two but it was about
thirty different defenses in one you
know so it was really intricate very
well I want to guest it every day and I
go well there's two safeties okay big
deal now you know they'd cover everybody
differently every time you drop back
right depending on your yeah right right
that was really cool really cool when
you think back what seal it was simple
but it was extremely complicated right
never gonna drink you ever like you're a
party with Bill Belichick I went to his
60s it was a 60th birthday party yes I
just got hired up there in New England I
wasn't invited but you were party so you
don't listen Bill's got a great personal
life he enjoys his all season you know I
know all those things
nobody wants I said now this is I just I
got pictures of you or you on stage
dancing with Bon Jovi and a concert and
he goes I don't know he said something
he sends if I ever see that you know he
threatened me kind of what okay I really
okay whatever you know he liked it he'd
like to go to concerts he likes to go
and and I've told you many times pretty
quick with it of course it's very dry
and man he can really slice you up
pretty good if you want to get in a
verbal war with him I know that so I
mean come on he's won all these Super
Bowls I'd be I'd be really confident and
cocky and everything if I went to eight
Super Bowls and I mean did he go as an
assistant three three other ones yeah at
least three yes what the Patriots yeah
and then you do with us yeah that's 11
11 Super Bowls
he is coached in so it's pretty pretty
interesting for for him so what else is
going on Adam what's going on in your
life uh I did the match this past
weekend with tiger and Phil I was
hosting that with Barkley and Samuel
Jackson I would say holes 3 to 14 3 to
16 were like that but I was hanging out
with Samuel Jackson so
that oh my gosh what a cool guy heaven
bar dad to him and Berkeley the story is
out of sky and Berkeley bettin on games
and doing oh yeah we were tell
afterwards going and just drink and he's
like Idol hey Adam I got a lot of money
Oklahoma Adam and I hope they pull this
out at him thank you know I tell you
their show their don t and tears at TBS
TNT yeah well whatever it's like you two
sitting here now during your show you
can just say whatever you want and you
can take 30 minutes to make one point
and usually you can't even get to the
point lost concentration or what the
hell you're trying to tell me and then
somebody interrupts them it's it's it's
it's worth watching them yeah but
there's a form of TV like that yes
there's just no it's not like you guys
where you get 12 seconds to explain the
Steelers defense
yeah no usually when it comes to me Phil
eight seconds seven six now go on I want
to take my paper throw up in the air JB
how you doing I'll ask my personal life
what's going on by the time they got to
me it didn't get to me they threw it
throw it back to JB and you know of
course and I know you know what's coming
up to that hey so that's some of your
best work you've ever done yeah put your
face on my hands oh it's all good I
appreciate suppose tipper tonight you
know Adam really yeah I'm gonna be there
okay we're going on a birthday party Raz
super-agent Steve yeah yep yep we're
gonna make Christopher he'll be the
youngest one there so I had to pick up
the check don't ruin his night rookie
hazing III are we getting like Chris
Collinsworth involved not coming out of
Kentucky to come up here that's
something he's gotta hit why he moves
away so he can't be involved in anything
he lives down here in Kentucky
then it's just you know listen living in
Kentucky who's not bad
taxes not a lot of people you know a lot
of good things yeah I'd like to take you
down there one time let go well he he
lived there dad he did he started you
know he was on Louisville News he was
the sports anchor so you know yes all
your family members I think I must
already know what station were you on
whas 11 so that's CBS right Kentucky
Anna's local Sports Network one of my
college Oh Liz Everman I think I went to
college with her and I used to go over
to her apartment and she'd be sitting
there rehearsing the news and she was a
news anchor in Louisville for I think
WLKY it would ask it was our rival
station yeah that would be ABC if I
remember and she was their lead anchor
at night for all my gosh I don't know 20
30 years she was he was great I'm better
many times over the years but when I go
back to Louisville we run into each
other at dinners or whatever it is so
she hasn't changed much and she's she's
doing great well there you go all right
you thank you for your time Phil have
fun at dinner great talking to you too
and no I never sent any dirty emails and
I didn't know that lime was in there I
did I do remember that you don't get
residuals all the time for all those
sitcoms and all those things I've been
on yeah and I love those checks when
they come in they come in about I got
about one or two a week and it'll be for
three dollars and ninety two cents I've
had a couple for Paul it's amazing yeah
big money I'm putting them into
Christopher's trust fund thank you all
right dad I'll see you later
I do think you could take Tom Coughlin's
III think you could oh thanks pal you
got it now that I have your support I'm
ready to fight god it's been so he's a
little out of shape right now
damn it yeah cuz he just eats a lot
that's how I doesn't sweat either but
he's definitely I've seen him with his
shirt off a few times lately and the
makeup room he's he's got a few extra
handles that he usually didn't have my
girlfriend likes to cuddle so I've never
happened
so you've got did we have a little
cottage cheese and we got a little
pretty good that was pretty great yes
negative ghostrider say over there did
the news EBU see if I remember I see her
sometimes when I go back she still does
hey how much you bench of these days pal
oh you got him going
watch out especially once you go going
down the football thing it just never
ends after that down like the Giants
thing the Giants thing storytelling time
Parcells Belichick I mean Fender Crone a
million times rap-rap rap-rap oh you can
trap I couldn't do it no I know I was
like Berkeley on Friday big mouth
alright let's get to some film all right
so honey he said that I've got the cover
to Patriots things I write that and I
know it's like I don't even know what I
wrote my notes but whatever will get to
you do not alright well let's start off
with Bills offense Jaguars defense
because of all the text message you sent
me the ones about Josh Allen excited me
the most okay you said the first thing
you notice about him is his presence on
the field second thing is damn yeah he
can [ __ ] and run I mean really run right
and there was one note about the
touchdown that many people have seen
first and 10 and you wrote QB draw from
first and 15 all those plays only get
called for the freakiest people on the
planet at the quarterback position like
first and 15 quarterback draw empty
formation against the Jacksonville
Jaguars the fastest defense on the
planet yeah I mean I guess you know
going back to what you said already
first up when you turn on the film he's
a guy that pops out the second he gets
out from underneath the center you just
go damn who is that big guy and he looks
like a good athlete drive him back we'll
see what he uses a quarterback I I know
that still yet to be determined but I
could tell you I like what I've seen so
far and presence is something out there
he does have a presence that team does
believe they have a chance when he's in
you know me I always look at people's
reactions how they play celebrating
touchdown dance with a Sean McCoy in the
endzone I mean Sean's not going like hey
let me find the sorriest dude on our
team and let's have a celebration dance
he's only gonna do that with the players
he thinks there are ballers up to his
level so I don't know why I went on that
ramp no you know his presence and his
physical ability were jaw-dropping in
the game and the reason they won the
game yeah you wrote only the really
physically gifted could have won this
game yes and I don't mean so like so to
say that again there's games where you'd
have to be a surgical you know
dissecting type passer where I'd go
that's not Josh Allen's game yet but I
would also say those surgical Tom Brady
drew breezes could have never won this
game playing quarterback for the Buffalo
Bills with that same talent around the
offense they ran there's no way they're
under man Jacksonville could cover them
with one eye closed and maybe one leg
taped to the other okay so there's
nobody to be too worried about their the
offensive lines nothing special you have
to be a phenomenal athlete to get out of
some of the situations to run for some
of the yards he had a boot boot passes
where nobody was open but he had enough
speed to turn the corner on tell them
Smith Orellana can gawk Way and get ten
yards or eight yards so yeah you have to
be really physically gifted as just an
athlete to do what he did in that game
I'll let alone the arm the arm scares
the defense to a degree where they're so
far down the field at times that when he
does scramble there's only one guy there
for him to beat because there's there's
there's six guys in the secondary forty
five yards down the field cuz he's about
to throw a Hallett sir down there this
sounds like what you say about mahomes
yeah that when other quarterbacks have
receivers going deep they don't got to
follow him as far right but the the fear
of his arm opens up running lanes for
him that other quarterbacks would never
get right right it's it's an
unquantified stat but you're right yeah
the other thing that you wrote I and
again you see things on film that would
pass me by and you wrote you know I love
the Jags but they're talking too much
yes they are what are you seeing on film
I mean just from get-go I mean I think
was one of the first plays of the game
he kind of runs over tell van Smith on a
boot
he runs the boot nobody's there and tell
the Smiths got his breakdown and tackle
him he kind of just goes fine I'll go
ahead I'll lower my shoulder and get two
more yards and he does and it's like an
eight or nine yard gain and tell what
Smith's gonna stand over them and talk
crap and you know anytime they have a
good play Jacksonville they're over
everybody letting them know and listen I
like that I'm all for that
but I'm not necessarily all for that
when you're three and eight and I'm not
all for that too when the other team
gives it back to you right so there's a
few times like that where Josh Allen
makes a big throw or makes a big run and
somebody's underneath them and miles
jack where and the linemen come down to
let him know or whatever they're saying
our quarterback just ran you over for a
touchdown and Jacksonville loses their
mind they go crazy they want to start a
fight right there and that just you know
again I'm all for being a bully on
defense and doing those things but when
you get bullied
you can't run across the field and get
in a fistfight with a guy I mean just
just too many instances like that where
their immaturity has shown this year
their handling of success has not been
very good and it bothers me just to be
where you are that state of the team to
kind of be acting that way like you're
the best thing going on earth right now
no I just think they have to dial it
back I hear sounds like a bruised ego
it's exactly right
it sounds like if anyone says like no
I'm the toughest right but to wrap up
Josh Allen you said his presence is
crazy
it's like Big Ben and Carson Wentz and
Cam Newton no one around him flusters I
mean at the end you wrote he's got a
chance to be big time he does I'm
hearing a lot of people selling josh
allen stock oh yeah like a few weeks ago
they're like Josh Allen doesn't look
giddy that good either and I'm like if
I'm in the media which I am right I'm
not saying any of these young guys don't
look good no cuz they've all shown hope
too but Josh Allen you still see the
big-time potential I really do
I I didn't you know he had some he got
unlucky with a few big completions that
got called back where I just was like
whoa that was an unbelievable throw not
really one dicey decision the whole game
except for maybe one
can remember out to his left he was
rolling to the left where I knew that
was stupid but everything else was smart
he understood the team he was playing
when he did make a type throw he threw
the ball in the right spot for the tight
throw might have not been complete but
it was safe where you're like that's
good Jacksonville get the pickin yeah
you know get the short field or whatever
it was so yeah he was very good that way
and hey we'll still see what he is I
understand that there's not a lot of
talent around him but I could tell you
this the guy has a chance to be really
special there's just not a lot of
quarterbacks that have the physical
tools he has I mean come on he scrambled
for a 45 yard gain and outran Yannick
and Gok way and tell van Smith and the
rest and AJ booyah it was like oh gosh I
got it like going to sixth gear to catch
this guy I mean come on that's that's
insane that's Lamar Jackson except it's
50 pounds bigger and that's how you
segue let's get to Lamar Jackson yeah
taking on the Raiders not the toughest
opponent but it's another week of seeing
him play more from the pocket right the
game plan for the Bengals was we're
gonna run him the game plan for the
Raiders was let's see him as a passer
I'll get to his flaws but the big note
that I saw is from the get-go to now I
still believe this kid is a natural he
has talent he's improved from week to
week wasn't perfect
but he's the best option for the team
what did you see now in week two of him
as a starter just comfort in the pocket
you know see in the field the right way
the two interceptions I have no problem
with those interceptions they weren't
egregious or stupid one of them was
deflected one of them was deflected the
other one was deflected to over the
middle right where he knew it was a
tight throw he knew it he tried to kind
of sidearm throw it hard and he was
hoping he could squeeze it by and the
underneath guy number 25 on the Raiders
the safety who I've kind of liked on
film I can't remember his name on top of
my head he hit the ball ball got
intercepted but I think just the quality
of the some of his throws they weren't
all perfect I know there was a few that
came out of his hand funny but man some
of the big completions I mean the ball
he's a natural thrower when he steps
into a throw gets his shoulder the
target has his back foot underneath them
man the ball comes out of his hand pure
every time I mean it's it's like a it's
that Michael Vick flick of the wrist
motion it's just effortless for him to
flick it 50 yards down the field or do
anything like that and then you know I
just thought he plated the game the
right way too he understood what he was
dealing with you know the risky
interception over the middle okay yeah
the scrambling was great and you know
they're running when they did ask him to
run was special the kids name is Eric
Harris Eric Harris that's right but you
did right look the play books not that
much bigger with Joe Flacco no when its
second in short third and short with
Edwards that o-line and Lamar Jackson I
don't know how you stopped all right and
I'm telling you I'm watching the game
I'm rooting for the Ravens cuz we're up
ten the lines ten and a half nine 300 on
them ten and a half right and when he
threw that bomb to John Brown yeah right
I lost my [ __ ] and Omar was here and I
went over to Josh and I was like Lukas
little Bors load a good quarterback
because he dropped it in perfectly to
John Brown yeah and then he ended the
game with a 40 yard run right he could
have tried to make a move and gone a
hundred but that's that's Lamar that's
the side of Lamar and it really I feel
like it's the Ravens were a team that I
picked to win the North they're a team
that I thought could have been talented
enough to win the one seat because their
old line is stacked their front seven is
packed their secondary has playmakers in
Jefferson and Weddell and some good guys
on corner and they got a lot of weapons
on offense I feel like could you tell it
from the film the whole team was
rejuvenated did it look like a different
team than three weeks ago yes it does
there's he is my concern is Ola Morris
played well against the Bengals and the
Raiders yeah I get that and I'm sure the
players still realized that too and I
bet you Lamar realizes it but you know I
bet you they also remember damn we
played some bad defenses already and it
wasn't like Flacco just tore them apart
and you know those are the things that
they're gonna remember too but he does
bring an energy to the football team he
brings an attitude to the football team
and they embrace it you can see that Joe
the quotes after the game right it's
like we got this guy he's crazy he's
like Michael Crabtree is like he does
stuff I've never seen right the running
has gone back to Louisville ish speed
everything he's in his car
for zone you're seeing everything that
we thought he could be start to flourish
he can put games away is he perfect
no but the big run at the end of the
game puts the game away huge he mean Gus
Edwards is such a big improvement over
Alec connage just a better combo with
him because he's a sledgehammer up the
middle and then you have to worry about
that he opens up holes for Edwards
Edwards opens up room for him on the
edge
he must you have the good special teams
right there playing Ravens football
they're playing Ravens full stop you on
defense cashew with Lamar I think the
field goals where you write and then
have an occasional big play which they
look for and that's where they strike
your big thing though yeah I saw from
your notes it's the thing that always
scares me with an athlete that can run
we saw it with Mariota I'm sure we're
gonna get there with Travis key and the
reason it scares me is because I
experienced it with Donovan McNabb and
you wrote don't try to be a pocket
quarterback right don't just stand there
did you sense that yeah yeah good burp
there saved it but there was yet there's
a few plays that's almost like going
back to Marcus Mariota I felt like his
rookie year wanting to be like the Red
Sea has parted run for 60 yards it's
there don't just stand there because
everyone's going we'd like to see you'd
be a better pocket passer I mean don't
forget what gotcha yes there was a few
moments especially early on in the game
where there was one within the pocket
where I wanted to there's nobody open
get out stop trying to wait for somebody
like just a miracle II get open and then
there was a boot he had to the right at
one point I want to say was the second
quarter maybe late first quarter where
nobody's open go run and get seven yards
it's there but instead he tried to make
some miracle throw to a guy that was
covered and those are little things
where I feel like in his head he's going
like oh I got a I got a show everybody I
can throw and execute this offense this
way no just execute it move the chains
and everyone's gonna go look at him
execute in the offense it doesn't matter
how you do it
people forget once it's successful and
then you could start to build on your
success from there I read these notes
and I go Sims so believes that Lamar and
Josh have a higher ceiling than Baker
Baker no question is better right now I
know yeah okay yes I would say man
Baker's impressed me too
a really good way to put it a year you
made me think there for a second yeah
maybe they're high-end
wow so you're really high on Baker I
mean a baker is amazing
yeah Baker's been really like really
good I mean well I appreciate about you
is you can go I was wrong
yeah yeah I should definitely not had
him three I know that I had Baker 3
right I had Josh Allen one Rosen -
definitely Baker should be - if not one
one would be more of if I made them -
it's just because I see that Josh Allen
ceiling is so high I'm gonna go with it
even though I know it might not be as so
you would actually go Baker one Allen -
who 3i Lamar Oh Rose I think I'd go
Lamar in a close one against Rosen and
then dartle define and Darla's v love
you Sam yeah yeah I think so that's the
way I'd do it man EXO Wow Baker is
really Wow
yeah I'll tell you what and if you want
some of my gambling advice right now
yeah I saw some of it yeah I saw in
Vegas that gambling guy say Quan is like
- 345 for Rookie of the Year and I think
Baker was like plus 150 with the way
that the NFL rewards quarterback play
and the way that the Browns schedule
sets up down the stretch the Giants are
gonna be a non-factor if the bit if the
Browns are even barely making the play
all right Baker's winning Offensive
Rookie of the Year right first pick of
the draft yeah if you can if you can get
plus 150 plus 175 right now I would jump
all over that with faker cuz - 345 why
even bet yeah you're right I mean it
says I was trying to explain that to the
guy on the set there I was like I was
like they were like well I think Tigers
gonna win and I was like yeah but the
odds are so much better on Phil that
you're obligated to bet on Phil right
like in a 50-50 situation you take the
better right right same that like oh you
think se Kwang's gonna win even if you
think that do not bet that way right you
should bet on where you can make a good
amount of money got you but anyway yeah
last thing on Lamar okay he just got to
get off first reads better okay that's
one of the big things I see more than
anything you know just cuz the coach
said this is the first read don't don't
hang on it so long he's got a few plays
where he doesn't and it's textbook and
he's perfect but there's also a few
times where he's sitting there in the
pock
can I just go move on move on he's not
gonna come open it's too late and then
it's oh gosh and people are around I'm
gonna get sacked or he has to throw it
away or whatever it is
he just that's one thing and like I said
don't forget to be a don't forget to be
a football player this is where you've
gotten if things don't look good get out
use your talents and make a play that
way you knew who was the best at that
Kaepernick
yeah Kaepernick was he would 95 yard run
60 yard
Pat's offense yeah this is an exciting
thing again make sure you check out Sims
and left go the show we had Denzel Ward
Sims and I talked about coaches on the
hot seat just you know Sims left on the
show fun coming up I think next week we
took Jamal Adams who you believe is the
best safety in the NFL yeah and because
you can't hit people anymore we took him
to a room where you can crush things and
smash things and that's coming up next
week very excited about it but you even
felt obligated to tell him about how in
love you are right now with the Patriots
power running game yeah you talked to me
about in the ober you yelled at a lady
behind us for beeping an [ __ ] she is
but you couldn't stop talking you would
just watch the film yeah it sounds like
you think the Patriots have the best run
game in the NFL I've never heard the
Patriots and best run game right it's
the best coach run game I'm not gonna
say it's the best because there's some
other teams that I think maybe you're
just a little more talented at the line
but they all overall offensive line what
does that mean best coach runs best
coach as far as creativity little
wrinkles on a weekly basis never really
schematically messin up what you're
supposed to do like execution right
let's just say there's you know that
sweet coaching that's the opposite well
the three they're not messing up the
execution of the play what you saying is
to a degree because I'm like saying like
this everyone so you guys got a picture
like this writers are doing what they're
being told to do they're being doing
what they told to do and even though
it's the same play the defense doesn't
line up in the same thing every time so
you have to have different ways to block
oh wait this time they lined up like
that we can't do the same thing we just
did when they lined up like this because
now this guy's just gonna run through so
they find
they communicated the line of scrimmage
to know like for instance like if you
have a three technique right you got a
three technique a guy on the outside
shoulder of that guard let's just say
it's the right guard right right okay so
it's well mean the guards attack right
and in that instance let's say the back
guard the left guards gonna pull right
okay yeah we're gonna use him to pull
that's great the center's gonna back
block the nose tackle eight okay now you
got a double-team on that three
technique between the tackle and the
guard yeah okay and allow that left
guard to swing around swing around and
one of those double teamers at one point
has to leave the double-team and get
something gets to the next linebacker to
cut him off from coming over okay so now
you can run the same exact play again
but let's say the defensive tackles are
switched around now let's say the three
technique is on the left and you still
want to pull that lever still want to
pull somebody so now maybe you have to
pull the center because now that me the
right guard has to block down right and
now the tackle has a guy head up on them
so you just go you take it okay you take
it okay guard you got to block the three
technique back side so you stay you
don't pull now the right guard down
blocks in the center poles and and that
you communicated at the line yeah yes
there's lots I learned and they're not
going they're going hey Jim you're gonna
take him and then I'm gonna pull him in
Tom because they're running a nose I'm
gonna need you to stay a Molly Molly or
DOOL DOOL or whatever it may be
everybody's got their own different
claws and they're gonna make those and
it's going so it's gonna be one word
that describes the defensive front and
then how they're gonna add we're not
even gonna talk about the defensive
front because when they literally are
walking up to the line of scrimmage
they're gonna go okay here's the front
we see it we better [ __ ] know what it
is because Carnegie has been drilling
into our brain and we've done nine
million walk through so they know that
they're already communicating about what
their call is going to be to how to
block it verse this front mm did I
explain that good things no I mean I'm
just football is such a complicated
sport it is so you get up there and then
what happens right right before the snow
the whole line goes and shifts to the
left right what do they do now if you're
too deep into your snap caps in case
like there are seconds left right you
can't stop it especially if you're on
like about to say set hut and if you
stop then someone's gonna jump offsides
so you gotta you there's nothing you can
do with that but everybody like Molly
ball they're doing something like that
definitely descended all the suddens
gonna go like bear bear burger and then
everyone's gonna try to figure it out at
the last then why doesn't every
defensive line shift at that time every
play well they could they certainly
could there's teams that do that every
now and then to set up Rico's who was
complaining about this just recently
about team shifting the Panthers doing
they were saying move right to simulate
the snap count they got somebody to jump
offsides that's a cheap trick that
defensive coaches will do what like that
[ __ ] down and also yell a real
aggressive move or something so the
center here is like I said you know it's
getting blue t5 booty buh buh buh you
know what a sense somebody jumps outside
that's that's cheating you're not
allowed to do that you're not allowed to
yell no yell like if there wasn't one I
got penalized so that's a very big
playoff game I think it was like last
year yeah but there was one even just
like two weeks ago where the teams were
complaining I can't remember it is no
but the reason to your point is why
teams don't always do that too it's
because you don't want to be caught
moving too much right of the snap right
because then you're gonna lose gap
integrity just like I'm telling like
think if you're going I'm over the guard
and at the snap you know or right before
the snap the coach wants me to get over
the center okay well you need to get
there and hunker down and get in your
position first if you try to do it why
they're moving and also now a guy is
blocking you as you're trying to move
over there right you're gonna end up
four feet to where you wanted to end up
right so that's why you have to be
careful about doing it too much whoo I
have forgot about this well this is man
we've been working together too long
2015 Cardinals are playing the Bengals
Sunday Night Football
Cardinals are about to try and kick a
46-yard field goal with Chandler
Catanzaro
and Peko yelled and they gave him a
15-yard unsportsmanlike penalty that
moved it to a 32-yard field goal that
they hit so it was on a field goal where
and then Marvin Lewis called it a
phantom call there was something that
happened just recently
I'm telling I remember that yeah and it
was like man that's how you're gonna end
the game yes so getting back to New
England's run offense though it's very
special yes and with Trent Brown healthy
and Shaq Mason being back and also you
wrote when they do 21 personnel it ends
up being two wide receivers right they
have not Edelman not Hogan not any of
these other
receivers it's Josh Gordon and
cordarrelle Patterson who you think are
the two top best run blocking wide
receivers in the NFL they're unreal an
aspect of the NFL that people don't
think about talk about right is the
ability to block as a wide receiver and
you think they're the two best they're
up in that combo yeah they're the two
best together on the field at the same
time like it's the best duo if you go
who are two receivers in the run game
that you could have be blockers that
have to get that safety who fills the
hole right or whatever maybe those two
are they're fearless they don't care
about Conklin wide receiver block is the
difference between a 10 yard run in the
third year exactly right why are they
unreal because they're just they're more
physical than your normal receiver right
they're just not afraid to go like Oh
Jamal Adams is there I'm supposed to
coach told me if the safety fills the C
gap it's my job this week to move them
out and they go in there and run into
them like a like you know a stud wood or
at least to the best of their ability
where you know Odell or Antonio they
might go in and just gonna go I'm gonna
get in his way and make sure nobody
falls on the back of my legs and I
shielded him or all gosh II got off me
and you got tackle it sorry man sorry
you know these guys are just a little
bit more of a hulking physical presence
to where they can move somebody like
that out of the way the way they use
Cordell Patterson I mean you know he can
almost be like a fullback he is such a
physical freak that way that I mean
they're had moments where they were an
11 personnel with three receivers and
but they played him at like a fullback
position and we're like you'll block the
Jamal Adamson insert through the line
there and he does unreal yeah nobody
wanted Randy Bill Belichick figured it
yeah
nobody wanted Cordero Belichick found
out I know nobody wanted OB melon Fon
woo and he's getting on the field to do
so Sims is man-crush lb melon Phan whoo
he's another guy that's jarring when you
turn on the film he's just like shocking
to see like the first thing I was like
first of all you know me I know every
number of guys I'm I was like 22 who the
hell is 20 and he's enormous
yeah and then I was like wait who the
hell is this and I couldn't i OB had not
struck my brain and of course I had the
roster up while I'm watching film and I
feel like oh my gosh that's OB holy cow
I mean he is he looks like a tall rangy
line back
her playing safe he's like 6 4 yeah I
mean he's how'd he do he did good he
didn't do anything bad um I'm not gonna
say he popped his size and speed once he
opens up does pop he didn't really get
to put that on full display it's like
they put him out there in the first half
to go hey man here's some useful reps
start to get yourself used to football
second half wasn't in there much but
that's Bella check next level stuff too
I can get away with this guy the first
half we'll call a few simple defenses he
won't screw up again him some reps he
might help us out in five weeks you
wrote down in your patriots defensive
notes 85 Bears Oh what did I write that
for something about the Patriots weekly
game plan stops what offenses do best
and that's what the Bears did oh yeah I
see the Patriots defense compared to the
85 oh okay okay okay this is what I was
saying I'm saying 85 Bears is done oh
that's what I'm trying to say like the
Patriots have figured out like you're no
longer gonna stop offenses to 150 yards
total offense and we're gonna keep them
to nine points no they've realized let's
be really creative and play good defense
and on a big snap and as long as we win
that snap we'll get the ball back and
get to do whatever we got to do oh yeah
you might have got a few first downs but
now we got you in the third down and
distance that we wanted to do it and now
I got a I got a defensive coverage that
like my dad was saying in the interview
earlier it might it looks like it's
covered too but it's cover two for this
week
it's not the cover two we studied on
film the last five weeks its cover two
verse this personnel set you know that's
where New England is next level it's
just it's it's it's it's the it's the
situational football that is not only
gained its game plan specific its
personnel specific its formational
specific it's situational specific it's
all of those together that make them
good and crazy it is is crazy and it's
just you know yes they are feared and
figured out like you're not gonna stop
offenses on every play but we're gonna
get them in that formation or that thing
where we go we got a beat on them here
we're gonna get off the field and then
we're gonna drive down the field score
touchdown they're just on another level
they are one team that try to knock them
off the Steelers and you said the
biggest weakness of the Steelers defense
is John Bostick in past cover yeah it
could be a real issue versus AFC team
right and you wrote they got to do what
the Ravens did with Ray Lewis at the end
yeah what are you talking about stick is
a your traditional meathead run stopping
middle linebacker right who just can't
run he just that's not in his game plan
don't got the right just doesn't have
the speed it's not what he's there for
and Denver did a good job of trying to
find out how he could cover a human or
anything like that why the tight ends
were so active and certainly summon the
first big one down the sidelines was
Hugh mermen on Bostick and he couldn't
keep up higher but heuerman sorry um
he's out for the year but yeah that
stinks but the the boss my point would
the Ray Lewis thing is like you know hey
they try to get him out they're out of
the game when there's obvious passing
situations but there's gonna be those
situations when they play new englander
Kansas City or hurry up offense right I
don't know what they're gonna do they
write down is not necessarily a running
down and right right they might smash it
up her mouth or they might throw a bomb
so we got to keep him on the field I
don't know and so what bravin's did with
Ray Lewis at the end of his career as
they knew he couldn't cover and they
didn't even want to put him in the zone
because they just rushed him exactly
right mmm just oh it's a big third down
you go back and watch New England AFC
championship games those last two times
they played when there was a big pass
play somebody dropped out of the line of
scrimmage and Ray bliss because they
were just like this is we he's not
perfect anymore he's not the best
linebacker in football he's still really
good he gets us all in the right spots
so we want him out there but he's a
liability when it comes to this
situation so how can we hide him in that
situation and that's what they did it I
think that's what they're gonna have to
do against the quality offenses in the
AFC I'm gonna skip now to Packers
defense Vikings offense Packers defense
Euro jire Alexander's when the best man
covers in the NFL yeah you also wrote
for Green Bay's defense with no Mike
Daniels Green Bay does not have one
legit difference maker in the front
seven now cuz Kenny didn't play either
Kenny played but you're good I'm not
gonna say he's a huge difference maker
not
the McDaniels like Nick Perry didn't
play Nick Perry's got a chance to be
different so you see disruptor disruptor
you're not gonna go Kyler fak role a
difference maker
no no Lancaster or Lowry they're just
our blank akina's or no they have a lot
of solid yeah well you thought the
defensive game plan was good they just
got out muscle okay exactly right and
you also said that Kirk Cousins didn't
make one bad decision he really didn't
so you're telling me can handle a
prime-time game this is a big deal he
won't care this week cuz the games at
4:25 and it's in New England so it's not
that big of a deal no because they know
it's not a big deal he's just to make oh
this is easy this is New England and no
way we're 25 so I don't have to worry
about the pressure of the primetime game
here speaking of the Packers though on
their offense
I actually saw our good old friend Aaron
Nagler whenever I need the beat of the
Packers yeah I just watch
Aaron Ziggler time line right but he had
one where it was the touchdown by Aaron
Jones and he wrote this is beautiful and
it was the one where they had the man in
motion the jet sweep faked it flipped
the run for the touchdown what do you
know Josh Sims in his notes wrote that's
a very nice wrinkle but then after
dot-dot-dot now you need 20 more well
you got to start somewhere
they got you've been asking for one for
five years not really they spent all
week on that one play that's been their
new thing they have like three plays a
week the pipe before that was a nice
screen pass to Aaron Jones I was like
what
oh screen I haven't seen that [ __ ] ever
you know the Seattle game on Thursday
night he threw a cool little screen and
then the next play they ran errands owns
out of the backfield member he ran the
corner out of the backfield
that was like what is this the Green Bay
Packer the Packers or am I watching the
99 Rams I was like whoa and then after
the second drive it's over like in that
my point there is just like yeah okay
that was a nice wrinkle those were two
nice wrinkles but Sean Payton has 30
more on a weekly basis so they're just
not capable no they're not I've been
saying that they don't know what they
don't even know that's what drives me
crazy you said we're not giving Sheldon
Richardson nearly enough no we're not I
mean about difference-makers on her
front seven [ __ ] the Vikings got five
I'll just on their front seven well
there's stars they got in the secondary
but I mean Griffin Sheldon Linville
uh-oh
Daniel hunter who's leading the team in
sacks and when the league leaders
Anthony bar Oh Eric head you're sorry I
was wrong they have six difference
makers on their front seven and the
Packers have none I mean okay if you
want to give Kenny Clark that
distinction sure fine sucks that's why
they got Muhammad will curse saying it
is Mike Daniels but we said it before
the year just like we say about the
Vikings yeah you got three yeah
they got to play 16 games right and if
you're lucky 20 right and do you really
think that those big ugly's are gonna
last the entire year exactly right it's
very dated of now the Vikings I will say
have a hair more depth than years past
yes they do you know
well Everson Griffin coming back and
playing at this level exactly and the
fact that Weatherly got all those reps
when Everson Griffin wasn't out right
that was helpful
you know I'm think I'm gonna mess up was
it is they up Tom Johnson or is that
Seattle that has time John I get
confused of the two guys that went to
Seattle one came back and one didn't I'm
gonna have to buy don't think Tom John
you mean
Sebastian what is Thunder bucket I got a
look so they called Tom Johnson I said I
should Thunder bucket it's gonna drive
me crazy I got a time roster Johnson NFL
he pops up for the Vikings he is he's on
the Vikings right now right cuz it's
Shamar Stevens who that wears the
Seahawks right
okay yeah so you got him Tom Johnson
Jaleel Johnson who's in the mix a little
bit this year and yes Sheldon
Richardson's played really good football
and is certainly a difference maker for
that team overall all right so I want to
talk about previewing Thursday night's
game it's such a good game that to only
talk about it that's all you want to
talk about with the Packers offense
thing yeah you know why why cuz you're
sick of it I don't need to know like we
talked about it guys here's what the
rest of the note said okay Aaron Rodgers
everybody's covered nobody's open his
degree of difficulty on the throws is
frickin insane
it's like they wouldn't even ask one
other quarterback of the NFL to make
throws like this it I read it every week
since I know and it's I'm not upset at
you but it just hurts my heart when I
read that
oh no it's absolutely right nobody's
open all the play calls are awful Aaron
Rodgers actually played great and then
for the last three days before we do
this podcast everybody
tells me that he's falling I know that's
why I wanted to say it cuz in case one
of those dummies is listening I would
like to educate them still he missed the
throw at the end of the game he did he
missed it nothing I could say gosh he's
horrible down he's officially out of my
top rankings no I mean yes he missed it
but the room for error for Aaron Rodgers
is so magnified because if you think
back at the game you're gonna go dim
that was really one of the only open
people I saw all night and he missed
them damn it
so that jumps out to your head where I
would just go there's a lot of other
offenses whether it's golf or Drew Brees
or or a Brady or anything like that I'm
not taking a knock on them I'm just
telling you they miss those throws on a
weekly basis too but you forget about it
because two plays later it's another 30
yard wide open guy completion and we
just go well they got the first down
it's not that big of a moment who cares
everything was good wasn't a turning
point in the game you know but you know
Rodgers
I mean Rodgers on their second touchdown
drive or was this their first one or the
second one I believe yes it was their
second one I mean it's come out of
play-action and nobody's going out
except the two outside receivers and
they're running 20-yard comeback whoa
and none of them are scary
so did Vikings receivers are like great
you're coming at me and I'm not scared
of any of you so he throws a out route
15 yards to Valdez scalding who's I mean
covered beyond covered like every other
quarterback were to go damn if I throw
that that's going to be a pick six he's
gonna undercut that but Rodgers just
goes I'll throw a laser perfectly and
we'll get it then the next play is same
thing I don't even know what the play
was crap on - that's how they broke the
huddle here's crap on - crap Bob - said
Hut break and they've gone to the huddle
and he drops back and it's a jailbreak
and now he has to run full-speed up into
the line of scrimmage
I mean full-speed sprint cuz he's like
oh gosh they're all collapsing on me I
had a run and without turning his body
or anything he throws a ball 35 yards
down the field on the sideline - a guy
perfectly who was covered to a tee and
I'm just telling you from a normal
unbiased I'm trying to be as unbiased I
can I'm just telling you no quarterbacks
would really attempt to do that except
for maybe Patrick Mahone's where they
would just go my
this is a target and I'm running full
speed and I'm just gonna do that and
throw it 30 yards and Trey Wayans is all
over my guy like white on rice but I'm
gonna throw it anyways BAM first down
okay and we just we just go let's good
play it's just not fair what's being
asked to him yeah compared to others
he missed the throw at the end there's
no doubt because he's about to go oh
here I come Debbie uw5 dummies
you know what starts with W but wick
John wick oh I thought you could say
win-win starts with that too Thursday
night Oh a ten and one New Orleans
Saints team that's 110 frickin games in
a row is going down to the big d Dallas
where after trading for Amari Cooper the
Cowboys can't lose three wins in a row
six and five sitting in first place in
the NFC East on one side and offense
that's cruising on the other a defense
that's punishing and DeMarcus Lawrence
came out and said this quote if you hit
a [ __ ] in the mouth and they
ain't doin what they regularly doin
putting up 50 points now you got him
where you want him at and then that
[ __ ] gets their gas choked out
and then you choked it then you
[ __ ] choke their ass I love
that Lawrence impersonations it's my
mark I love DeMarcus Lawrence saying
this I love him saying that this is do
or die
I love a leader coming out and saying
because this is not just a normal game
right this is a nationally televised
game with a normal week's rest against
the cream of the crop in the NFL Dallas
is feeling themselves New Orleans is
obviously feeling themselves and I know
that you think that this is going to be
a game that fits New Orleans perfectly
the strength of the Dallas defense
getting a pass rush the strength of the
Saints offense their offensive lines
amazing and Drew Brees throws it within
two seconds
offensively oh man the Saints are the
number one run defense in the NFL and
all the Cowboys can really do is run and
it's gonna be about am re Cooper 50/50
balls against Lattimore I don't know
what it is I think it's because the
Cowboys were in the situation a few
years ago a five loss Cowboys team I
don't have the underdogs it's the Saints
after they just beat the Falcons but
there's something about this game that
feels weird to me Sims yeah feels like a
Cowboys win okay it does they're
definitely the more desperate team we
know that you know yeah as much as I say
they match up good with the Cowboys to
the Cowboys are one of the better
matchups for the Saints I mean they are
they're gonna be able to go okay your
old lines not just gonna overpower us
right they're gonna go rough seven we
can play man-to-man everything Byron
Jones can play Michael Thomas man-to-man
we can live with that Geno Smith and
Layton Vander rush can go side to side
with these guys I get you I shut down
the Falcons offense eight they
definitely can I mean I get that and the
Falcons are not the Saints though I know
that but but no I'm with you I don't
what's the spread of this game just
seven and a half seven em yeah I think
it's actually down to seven is it it is
not but some casinos at status I would
probably go to Cowboys if you just went
on Sims and left go last night the
Saints
to cover to win to cover yeah it's a
close one I don't know hey he's not a
good gambler I never said that I think I
even said to you than if it was close I
thought like maybe if they win by
morning
put it away with like a late touchdown
yeah right so I just want to file it
with that or qualify it
I don't know qualify it but either way
break it down
Saints offense Cowboys diva right I mean
Saint I mean Cowboys defense is special
okay but so was the Saints offense and
all the different ways they can hit you
and I just don't know if the Cowboys at
the end of the day they can physically
match up with the Saints and give them
hard times you know Joe versus Joe I
just don't know if the X's and O's can
match up with the X's and O's bold
prediction yeah this is the first game
right where taste and he'll tries to run
over somebody
oh and gets run over to much right I I
believe that this is gonna be the and I
think there's something weird about the
Saints and Taysom
Taysom Hill is like boobie miles in
Friday Night Lights where the hot like
he's there energy guy and I think Taysom
Hill is gonna get popped on Thursday
night and they're all gonna look at each
other and they're gonna be like oh [ __ ]
and then Layton Vander I should be like
I'm the only crazy white guy on this
field flip it around yeah
Cowboys offense Saints defense this just
feels like two fists punching each other
it does yeah I'm nervous before talking
about Sheldon Rankin yeah Sheldon
Rankin's has been like one of the
under-the-radar best defensive players
in football the last four to five weeks
I mean he is I swear to you the first
four or five weeks of the season I would
have gone man Sheldon rank has just
never panned out just never is I don't
ever notice him on film gets moved in
the run game and I don't know what
happened but just as the year went on he
starts the win want more one-on-one
battles pushing guards back into the
quarterbacks face slipping through gaps
I mean he's become a true disrupter so
that's what's awesome about them they're
d-line their front seven they're balls
to the wall I mean just like Dallas is
they don't look to tackle you they look
to rip your head off
who are these guys well they're I know
Kim Jordan I know Sheldon Rankin's if
Davenport's out there that's big sure I
guess a Jay Klein
yeah well the mario davis is a really
physical guy inside right yeah you know
you got your Hendrickson's you got your
Davison who's a good player they're
backup Davidson's 995 right these are
not guys that people talk about they're
not these are more big hulking physical
guys that will never be stars but every
good defense needs these type of guys to
you know hold down the fort Davidson 262
309 pound guy you know they got omen
yata who's six for 300 pounds we talked
about Trey Hendrickson they have a lot
of just big all-around good football
players who have good athleticism really
have no weakness they might not be
really really great at anything but they
all are real good and have no weakness I
think that would be the thing I would
say about them on the demons aside hey
they're secondaries kind of figured it
out as far as the way they want to play
they're gonna play man here and there
but they don't live in it anymore like
they did early in the
and they're gonna just play sound zone
defense and they got athletes on the
back end too none of them are maybe
great cover guys like that but they got
speed and when they see the ball thrown
they're very good at rallying making the
tackle and they're good enough to wear
oh it's third and four we can't play
zone we need to maybe blitz and let Eli
apple and Lattimore play an island a
little bit they can do that it's gonna
be scary though and I have a lot Amari
Cooper will be a handful for whoever got
guards hit I mean a handful it's so cool
to see you Mary Cooper happy now going
back to your original Jamarcus lawrence
quote okay my thing would be this you're
not the first badass [ __ ] the
Saints have seen this year and their
coaches Sean Payton who was one of the
league leaders and being a badass
[ __ ] himself and he's gonna let
them know what they're in store for I
think they banished [ __ ] they
faced on the road you think that you're
gonna call them better than the Ravens I
am okay
I'm gonna say that the defensive line of
the Cowboys has scarier people than the
Ravens yeah the Ravens are trying to
clog it up I know they'll get after the
quarterback yeah they're more big and
physical base this time has a little
more explosion ball you up base I think
you're right I mean that I don't
disagree but I'm just saying this ain't
the first this ain't the first slugfest
of the year I mean they went to
Baltimore to Minnesota Rams at home
they're not going oh gosh it's the
Dallas Cowboys I don't know how we got
to this point at ten in one and they out
Baltimore Baltimore involves all
tomorrow exactly I mean when you do that
you're you're you're battle-tested yeah
I just you know but I hear you I left
ghosts talking himself into this I'm so
into it right now I really talked about
Friday morning whoa I'm really
interested to see the Byron Jones
Michael Thomas matchup because I think
Thomas's are gonna have an inch I think
you know I think that'll happen I mean
Michael Thomas is really hard to cover
I mean Aris stop even when he's covered
but yeah Byron Jones is at least the
type of guy that really I think can give
him a run for his money in any
one-on-one situation even with the 50/50
back shoulder ball go be a woozi is
gonna be all over TRACON smith hey he's
player Alvin Kamara is gonna get popped
I love mouthing come on [ __ ] groan
all right that was fun yeah good stuff
from your dad really brought the energy
today super pumped hope your bets are
gonna go well tonight for tomorrow's
podcast because you have some catching
up today and there are five big
differences and I went five and oh gosh
how much more are you up on me we'll
find out on that Friday podcast against
the spread for sips peace out homey
Fenric says good evening I'm the lef koe
[Music]
you